digamos que tenemos al número 5 y nos
preguntan qué número necesitamos sumarle
para llegar al 0 a lo mejor ustedes ya
saben esto de todos modos lo voy a
dibujar así que tenemos aquí una línea
de números y el 0 lo colocamos en esta
posición el 5 vamos a colocarlo en esta
otra ahora para ir del 5 al 0 hay que
movernos 5 espacios a la izquierda eso
quiere decir que tenemos que sumar de
forma negativa 5 o se hace menos 5 así
que si agregamos menos 5 eso nos trae de
nuevo al número 0 muy probablemente tú
ya sabías esto pero esto es algo que
requiere de mucho sentido común de hecho
existe todo un nombre rimbombante para
la propiedad de la inversa de la suma y
vamos a escribirlo yo creo que es algo
ridículo ya que es una idea muy sencilla
pero esta es la propiedad del inversor
aditivo y esa lo único que tiene es la
idea de un número al que le vamos a
llamar un número
negativo que si le agregamos a tu número
original volveremos al 0 porque tienen
el mismo tamaño y lo puedes ver de esta
manera ambos tienen la magnitud de 5
pero este es hacia la derecha y este es
hacia la izquierda al igual que si
empezamos en 3 negativos vamos a
pintarlo empezamos en un 3 negativo que
está de este lado y alguien nos
preguntará que hay que sumarle para
volver al cero entonces ya vimos que nos
hemos movido 3 lugares a la izquierda ok
entonces que le sumamos para volver al 0
bueno tendremos que movernos ahora 3
espacios a la derecha y esto es en
dirección positiva así que hay que
sumarle 3 positivo ahora si sumo 3 a 3
negativo llegaremos al 0 así que en
general si tenemos cualquier número por
ejemplo 1.725.000 314 y digo que el
numero necesitamos para volver al 0
bueno tendremos que ir esencialmente a
la dirección opuesta
tendremos que ir hacia la izquierda
entonces vamos a restar
la misma cantidad o puedo decir que voy
a sumarle la inversa o en la versión
negativa del número así que es lo mismo
que sumar menos 1.725.000 314 y eso me
devolverá al número 0 ahora similarmente
que el número necesito sumarle a menos 7
para llegar al 0 bueno si ya estoy en
menos 7 hay que sumar un 7 positivo que
es movernos 7 a la derecha y eso será
igual a 0
todo proviene de la idea general de que
5 menos 5 o el inverso aditivo de 5 o el
5 más el negativo de 5 todo esto es lo
mismo que 5 menos 5 y si tienen 5 de
algo y quitan esos 5 entonces ya
aprendieron hace muchos años que así se
obtiene el cero